bonjour et merci de prendre le temps de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
est ce que vous êtes inquiet aujourd'hui
quelle est la situation dans votre
hôpital alors on va dire il existe un
certain nombre de signaux d'inquiétude
pourquoi pour que bien sûr le niveau de
spéculation du virus dans la population
augmente
comme vous l'avez rappelé il est
aujourd'hui d'environ 12 nouveaux cas de
contamination
cent mille habitants et ce taux augmente
régulièrement avec des valeurs et paix
dans les grandes métropoles sommes à
paris alors dans les hôpitaux on
commence à voir arriver un certain
nombre de patients infectés par le
groupe id alors qu'on en avait pas dans
en partir de mi mai du mois de juin
aujourd'hui en ile de france environ 60
pour hospitalisés ou une pompe grave de
prove it en réalité d'une façon générale
c'est lé cas de contamination dont on
parle ces derniers jours ces dernières
journées est ce que ce sont des malades
plutôt asymptomatiques plutôt grave
qu'elle tranche de la population est
davantage concerné es ce que vous avez
quelques éléments sur ces points alors
la très grande majorité des
contaminations ce fait essentiel froid
dans les chais les personnes jeunes 20
et 40 ans néanmoins certains propos de
camille nation aux deux les personnes
plus âgées au comportant des facteurs de
risque de faire des formes graves et
alors du coup puisque ce sont
aujourd'hui majoritairement les plus
jeunes qui semble toucher contaminé
contaminée par le coc u19 est ce que là
la situation est un peu moins alarmantes
que ce qu'on a connu au mois de mars par
exemple alors oui la situation est pas
encore extrêmement également puisque les
hôpitaux ne sont pas débordés les cas
graves d'ailleurs réalisé en réanimation
semble légèrement moins graves lors de
la première vague
malgré 12 c'est une affaire de
statistiques le nombre de personnes
contaminées en plus le nombre de
personnes à risque de faire une forme
grave ont taclé va augmenter et plus le
nombre de sorts de graves admis dans les
services de réanimation pas au fond et
donc notre crainte évidemment c'était
que à l'arrivée de l'automne et bien les
personnes plus fragiles plus âgées
voient plus aminés et qu' il y ait un
afflux elle vaut plus important que
chante plus graves vers les autres
dans les cas de contamination
aujourd'hui dans les cas que vous
recevez à l'hôpital est ce que vous
voyez une différence dans les symptômes
dont la maladie avec ce qu'on a connu au
début en tout cas lors de la première
vague est ce que vous avez le sentiment
que la maladie elle a évolué de quelle
sorte
non je ne crois pas que la maladie
évolue évidemment on voit comme déjà dit
beaucoup de formes asymptomatiques ou
plus d'infos petit et en moins chez les
personnes sans défense grave
jol même type de tableau est à dire une
fumerie diffuse a créé dans la totalité
de hauts responsables insuffisance
respiratoire est en manque d'oxygène et
justifiant et un apport nécessaire de
kant et croissante d'oxygène
juste au moment du fail sert une
ventilation arrière car la personne
n'est plus qu'à part par elle-même de
respirer alors pour se prémunir d'une
deuxième vague
les autorités françaises appellent à la
vigilance ont
à dire on le répète ces derniers jours
et les mesures sanitaires sont de plus
en plus forte qui restreignent notamment
certaines libertés à en croire certains
avec notamment le port du masque
désormais obligatoire dans un certain
nombre de communes en france
est ce que cela vous semble une mesure
utile indispensable nécessaire quel
regard que vous portez
alors il faut évidemment que ces
décisions de port du masque espace
ouvert à da pts et à la situation et
biologie comme dans un certain nombre
d'endroits notamment dans les villes
balnéaires l'incidence des nouveaux cas
de contamination il paraît logique et
une cellule au préfet prenne ce type est
idiot néanmoins ces décisions de port
obligatoire du casque dans l'espace
public faire rester limitée zones les
plus à risque où il ya densité
importante de deux personnes de
touristes à la fois pour rassurer la
population les touristes commerçants
mais aussi peut-être réduire le risque
de alors le problème évidemment c'est
que avec le retour des vacances et la
fin d'été vers les grandes métropoles
je risque va se déplacer vers les
grandes villes doubiens sur bet que des
grandes villes comme paris commence à
prendre des décisions de port
obligatoire du masque long des berges
m et dans certaines rues il ya une
densité a entre nation attendu merci
d'avoir pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions au bonhomme égard barbe
je rappelle que vous êtes un chef du
service réanimation à l'hôpital
lariboisière à paris